speech hating liberals in a full-blown
panic now that Elon Musk is set to take
full control of Twitter the world's
richest man buying the company for 44
billion dollars and is set to take it
private musk saying this quote free
speech is the Bedrock of a functioning
democracy and Twitter is the digital
Town Square where matters vital to the
future of humanity are debated
conservatives celebrating this is a win
for free speech while liberals
are holding a funeral from the platform
R.I.P Twitter and leaving Twitter have
been trending all day Greg what does
that tell you though that that Twitter
is now going to be Freer and Liberals
are upset because imagine your favorite
restaurant you know is under new
ownership and it was it went from vegan
to barbecue
it's no longer preferred treatment for
the left right you don't get the best
table by the window anymore everybody is
now the same uh he just he basically
took control of the media's diet because
Twitter is their journalistic Buffet
spread that's where they go to get all
their stories and this is why there was
a problem with Twitter an elevated
extreme uh takes uh you know anointed by
like a pocket of hysterics there's not a
lot of people that are there's like 10
that are constantly you know putting out
crap the joke about CNN was that it was
never run by Jeff Zucker it was run by
Twitter right it was their producers
going to find out what's the the
screamiest take and then that and what
happened that led that led the network
down the drain so uh musk isn't like a
guy who bought a fast expensive car he's
like the world's best mechanic buying a
fast expensive car this is a guy who can
go under the hood and go uh I see that
algorithm I know what that is we should
change that and he said he's going to
put some sunlight on the algo so we see
how it really is rigged I wonder if
he'll let everybody Look Backwards too
to see you know what what was going
through the Twitter headquarters when
Babylon B was
um blocked open up the books I don't
know are we going to be able to see uh
someone one day will write an amazing
best-selling book about the behind the
scenes of all this and Fox Nation will
do a documentary series that we'll all
be able to see I also I actually posted
by Baron Trump maybe I don't know how
it's all going to turn out
forward we're in negotiations I try to
look forward and then think okay so I
like like looking at Twitter for
breaking news and also for our snarky
comments from Greg but in a month are
those going to be there I don't know
well someone said today that if Liberals
are upset with Twitter now that musk
owns it they can form their own platform
that has more censorship yeah that's
right they can censor themselves but
look this is not only a big win for free
speech it is about a big ship that's
coming I think that what's going on
around the country is with when you saw
the picture and we'll we'll talk about
it later the pictures of all the
Democrats who are now in favor of some
kind of resolution of what's going on at
the border and now we've got someone
who's going to take over Twitter who
actually believes in the Constitution
and free speech and you know people are
fed up there's a big shift that's why
this is going to go beyond what happens
in a midterm but I think that uh had
they not sold to uh Elon Musk the
shareholders would have had a real
lawsuit against them you're right so
Geraldo are you going to be posting any
shirtless photos of yourself in fact let
me know you whip this out right now
Elon Musk fan and I I assume because
he's a genius that this is a good deal
for him but looking as a layperson from
the outside and I have no Insider
information having heard that Donald
Trump about two hours ago or an hour and
a half ago announced that he will not be
going on Twitter to me that was the
biggest part of the deal that's what
made Twitter so valuable
compared to the old days because Donald
Trump was going to come back and I
remember just my own experience and
losing 50 000 followers when Trump all
the rest of it but everybody uh you know
lost that 400 000. why do you think he
said it because he owns truth social
because he's also maybe he won't be
tweeting it'll be true thing and he's
gonna I don't know you know knowing him
for so many years I think he'll change
his mind in 10 minutes he will but if
he's indeed sticks with this and stays
off new Twitter new Twitter won't be
worth as much as I thought it would be
well who cares though because many
people believe that Trump hadn't been on
Twitter so much he would have been a
little more of effective president that
is true that is true I think that this
is bad news for Truth social because
he's not going to be able to help
himself
he's going to hop back on but you
mentioned Babylon uh Babylon B and uh
Kyle Smith made a good point on Twitter
that it was the suspension of Babylon B
that probably led to this because it
pissed off uh it pissed off Elon Musk he
saw that he goes wow they can't do that
and then he said maybe and then he did
that little quiz should I buy Twitter so
I mean think about that having so much
money that you can just get mildly
irritated over something and then buy
yeah the thing that irritated you that's
true that's my dream
Perfection I know I want to buy Delta
Airlines hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else